it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes what in the world movie fights is
happening right now
hashtag movie fights live open to the
party everybody oh and a very special
welcome to Al nation hashtag al nation
hoot-hoot personals in the house JT no
al picture this week all right can't
have everything you want in life thanks
buddy all right we got some awesome
fighters in the house ready to throw
down have some good times here making
his formal movie fights debut you I saw
you movie fight wonderfully at WonderCon
recently I didn't mean to say wonder
Troy's gonna work just worked out that
way Eric Goldman party thank you
managing editor a fandom and all-around
swell guy thank you thank you very much
yeah my if I did like a lightning around
one two years ago and I did the Wonder
kind of way that this is my first
official official movie fight right on
brother and it looks like you've been in
the dojo getting ready and trying it a
try yeah pain does not exist in movie
fight oh I want to welcome this
gentleman back to the party are you on
he is the country's premier scholar on
all things ava duvernay and he's regular
in Collider live welcome back Josh
McKoon Thank You Hal thank you a
pleasure to be here I spoke to Ava on my
way in today and she is psych from high
return to movie fights a huge fan of all
the things I've ever said about her in
all the movies the first that I've never
seen that you argue for strike card no
mercy yes looking forward to that kind
of fun today and she is off the couch
and at the table she's you know from all
over screen junkies to one of the hosts
of the tights and fights wrestling
podcast
Danielle Radford Danielle now last time
you movie fought you you won and you
like swept the whole thing will not
happen today
you clearly never fought before cuz
almost as impressive as that though you
I don't know if you cursed once whereas
usually like is like just carpet bombing
f-bombs I know it's the worst but now I
work here so it's like I can I have to
pay attention to what gets us
demonetized and stuff because some of
that monetizing gets me cool suspender
outfits like this oh yeah okay I've got
something in the game now
nice all right well you know I even
without the cusses still love you right
here
Thank You Danielle and keeping score and
just keeping sense of all the nonsense
got Dan Merle and Billy biz Merle biz
we really build an bridges over here
thank you Dan we'll be holding it down
factually and Billy
mr.william business you will be our
social media conduit they're talking to
the people well let them know how that's
gonna work sure how I'd love to
procrastinate on the work I'm supposed
to be doing right now so I can hang out
with you guys you can hang out in the
chat today and then for voting all you
got to do after everyone gives their
opening statement and they argue for a
little bit you can just turn the
annotations on and off you can vote I
will look at the YouTube poll in the
case of a tie if you have no idea what
I'm talking about
it's in the description Ryan's on the
couch in the chat he'll help you out but
it's going to be a fun one today good
sign all your ava duvernay facts yes the
school Josh the entire answer yes
absolutely
well again how this works the first
person to score four points will be our
winner after the first three rounds we
go to the speed round and the top two
players progress on to the speed round
and it's anybody's game from there you
can be down three zip and make a furious
comeback you want to do a little movie
fighting you guys I mean why not do a
jte package please
he does he feel from her friend
yeah yeah thanks door okay let's go to
question number one Oh so uh yeah Sonic
broke the internet this week and I scan
it a total redesign fans are up in arms
so we asked what's the worst designed
character from any movie worst designed
character from any moving Eric we start
with you I looked at a franchise that
gave us so much in bad character design
and then I chose the one that stood out
the most which is Devastator from
Transformers Revenge of the Fallen
that's the second of the five terrible
Michael Bay Transformers movies uh yeah
look if you look at that you go what the
hell am I looking at and that's exactly
I think my point about Devastator is
they took the idea of combining robots
it's such a popular thing in
transformers and they took the terrible
designs that are in the Michael Bay
transformer movies and then they put
them all together into an even worse
design so it's just mashing one thing
after the other on top of it and you
can't tell what the hell you're looking
at so I think that's what makes it stand
out is just it's nonsense on screen what
the hell are we looking at Thank You
Erik Josh see the face I'm Megan I'm
with you yeah all right
mine is Howard the Duck clearly the
movie that ruined everybody who thought
that George Lucas could do a follow-up
to Star Wars and instead made the
creepiest duck in the world I'd like to
say that that Howard the Duck it made a
furious comeback and a vendor's end game
as shown to me in a like some tiny
little screen grab where we had a
machine gun but this hour the duck is a
lot like when they tried to make you
know the spin-off of of Seinfeld and
they gave us Kramer or the spin-off of
friends and gave us Joey they just gave
us a really weird version of a duck man
human that was looking at one point we
saw duck boobs which was all part of the
Howard the Duck universe and we were
supposed to believe that a duck that
could barely walk that had seriously bad
osgood-schlatters of the knee and
had really no business running towards
any heroic effort and somehow that was
gonna be the end I'll save all of alia
Thompson who was really just trying to
be a rock star and for some reason we
even got a bestiality scene which I
don't really know what that was other
than we got a duck tail boner and I am
still scarred emotionally infinite and
spiritually for what we saw in Howard
the Duck all right Thank You Josh by the
way if you could tell me what
osgood-schlatters is it's at how well
first I want to say if you'd like to
know more about Howard the Duck you can
check out the honest trailer that we did
a couple of weeks ago but I will be
fighting today I made more suspender
dresses all right
so mine I'm going with is it's a
character from the nineteen the 1990s
film spawn
I chose not gonna get this right ma
bozhe who is the villain and the devil
that is about one of many horrible
character designs he is this characters
ugly for any movie it's not just ugly
for this movie the character design is
wildly inconsistent in some scenes it is
practical in some scenes it looks like
this which is like a bad child's
refrigerator drawing of the devil they
had only heard of what it was once while
they were half asleep
it was the you know the production was
rushed so most of the design problems
happened because they were only given a
couple of weeks to do these and it not
only is it a bad design because it
obviously looks terrible
a part of being able to do good design
is knowing what your limitations are and
working within them and the creators of
Malgosia clearly did not resulting in a
mess of three different kinds of being
essentially three different models for
one character hmm man that's a real real
[ __ ] show going on with all these
characters let's fight it out
I would say first of all that I buried
my lead which is robot testicles I mean
all of your characters are ugly let's
say and yes there are duck boobs but did
they have scrotum no that's what
Devastator brought to the party but
everybody knows robe if you're gonna do
robot balls those robot balls will come
in because then when he transforms into
a tractor-trailer it'll be the balls
hanging from the trailer but which came
first the tractor or the balls good it's
a good question is as important as
talking about Robo testicles it is one
thing I do have to say about Devastator
is you mentioned that it was ugly it
didn't make sense well that is a
consistent in the design of the movie so
you can't really single this out as the
worst design of that movie or the worst
one here that's what all of them look
like and you mentioned that it just
looked like a bunch of mishmash of parts
for me that's what makes it work it is a
robot that eats other robots and then
uses their resources to become another
robot and so what it winds up becoming
is this hulking mutated awful looking
grotesque robot because essentially it
is what happens when you just stack
robos on top of robos on top of robots
with Howard the Duck you know duck boobs
notwithstanding we can't cap those those
were those were his we can only count
his and we did not get to see his dumb
oops
whoo duck pecs you know that that design
may not have necessarily worked for a
Howard the Duck that we are used to but
it very much worked for the humor in
this Howard the Duck the thing with Mal
Bhoja is that this is supposed to be the
height of the movie and the design takes
you so out of it because it goes from
looking you know at some points you know
because of the realism and because they
use practical it goes from looking like
an xbox one thing to looking like
Dreamcast Sega I love you but it does
let me let me listen the devil it does
look like a really bad painting on a
Venice Boardwalk that like your creepy
college roommate freshman year bought
somewhere and then put on the wall to
scare you when you got home I agree with
you on that one now did that take away
from the actual movie no did it ruin the
movie and transformers no did Howard the
Duck the actual Duck ruined the movie
yes Howard the Duck came free ruined
that movie was ruined from the time the
pen left the paper even even as that
creepy feathered claymation automatron
ik puppet duck man root not only could
have there was someone in the sea there
was someone in the suit if there is not
one of yours did not ruin a movie quite
like Howard the Duck in future where
we're like oh look at the end of
guardians of the galaxy that's the
Howard the Duck we all should've been
drinking to martini everybody still as
soon as they're done you can tell it is
Howard the Duck and at least you can
tell it is pop oh sure am I saying that
name right devil because that character
the real thing there is that the effects
weren't up to par because I think if you
look at the design like it that looks
like an early does a drawing of what the
character could look like they just
couldn't actually bring it to life
whereas Devastator they had the best
effects in the world they had like ILM
at their prime it's just that their
actual design you couldn't make out what
you were looking at and in the classic
you know incarnation of Devastator he is
construction vehicles you can tell
that's a mixing truck and that said you
know a forklift here it's just all
mashed together so they're taking away
the thing that makes that character
static doesn't much is what makes him
look so terrifying and horrifying
because when you see him and he's
climbing up that pyramid and yeah f you
for making me have to watch scenes from
tournament from terminator from
transformers to by the way when he's
climbing up there he looks not like a
slick robot but he looks like something
new and terrifying that you hadn't seen
before I think it works great for the
movie as it was all the Transformers are
kind of weird let's say I think we can
all be an agreement that humans can't
beat the transformer we got lucky five
straight times and it's just for plot
points okay the Devastator is just he's
another creepy looking robot I can't
tell the difference between the good
ones and the bad ones so they're all
badly designed I don't think that Balboa
you know
Robert Robert loggia it really did this
the movie of disservice the thing I keep
getting back to the movie is called
Howard the Duck and the worst part of
the movie was the duck I would argue
that the worst part of the movie was all
of the movie either the plug your
argument is centered simply on how bad
the duck looks and how bad the
construction is there are moments when
the duck is walking when the duck looks
great there's a moment at the end where
the duck is playing guitar and it's like
looking you know looks just like Michael
J Fox if he was a duck that wanted to
also then it's a woman realizes light on
J Fox Marty McFly into a duck and I will
not stand for that yeah again the design
was great he looked really good he had
feathers that one you're lying to
yourself you're lying to yourself right
now if you think that that duck look
good pass it like the Disney Sister
Sister Sister theme park that exists
somewhere in Omaha because they still to
pay the land grants annexed into this
argument right let's reel it in shift
gears and Eric we'll go to some final
thoughts please previous I would argue
that you know you were saying her the
Ducks the title character but Devastator
is also a title character he's one of
the Transformers and yes all the
Transformers designs are bad in those
movies but he is the king this is most
symbolic one of that bad design because
he's the one that you can tell the lease
what's going on he's top-heavy he
doesn't even look like he could be able
to walk if you looked at his full design
which is very hard to do because he
looks so bad
nothing about him works I think about
him is distinct you can kind of see a
mouth and that's it so he is the
greatest symbol of a series it failed
its title characters and he is one of
those character me thank you Eric
Josh yeah I mean Balboa and devastate
her you know terrible designs we can all
agree on that but what we can't agree on
is that at one point a duck was brought
in and all the people in the room agreed
that this is what the duck in Howard the
Duck should look like he really honestly
looks like a very scared teenager that
got a bad haircut his mom took him to
get a perm and has kind of a weird skin
condition and that's just basically what
we're getting of a design of a man named
Howard the Duck Thank You Danielle I
think Howard the Duck might have been
the right duck for this movie but if you
put that in a ducktales movie or any
other movies a cartoon movie that
can't read water with a Devastator yes
he doesn't look like he can walk upright
but in fact there are moments when he's
mostly crawling while he's trying to
figure out his new weird mutant body I
think that how unsettling he is compared
to the rest of the robots that very much
look like robots that are somewhat
recognizable is the point of it with Mal
bozhe the major problem is that the
design is so terrible it takes you out
of the climax of the movie and all you
can think about is that that looks
terrible and I think that there it's one
thing to have a horrible design that
maybe doesn't look like anything which
again and transformers that's the entire
movie so it doesn't take you out of
anything that essentially ruined spawn
and that's why I think it's the worst
design time all right some good stuff
some terribly designed characters let's
see who is good slaughters the
competition Dan takes to the facts own
how according to the Mayo Clinic Osgood
slaughtered disease could cause a
painful bony bump on the shin bone just
below the knee yeah usually occurs in
children and adolescents experiencing
growth spurts during puberty
no word on if it afflicts ducks I salute
you thank you sir
Josh also mentioned the Disney Sister
Sister Sister theme park in Omaha there
is a park called the Funplex water and
rides amusement park in Omaha Nebraska
but I can find no information that it is
officially affiliated with it does it
have a duck mascot not that I can see
not that I can see rival 2l nation I
guess rival duck nation Dan thank you so
yeah a lot of good stuff going on here
as far as your arguments Josh I feel
like you know you you know hit that gong
that is like the the badness of Howard
the Duck but we we kind of just hit the
same note we didn't
civics there and I felt like I heard a
little bit more from Eric and Danielle
so it came down to these two for me and
I'll tell you what Danielle I thought
made the more interesting point to me
the fact that like I'm I haven't I don't
recall it but I'm disgusted by the fact
that it was CGI and then practical and
back again but Eric also made some great
arguments about just how you couldn't
discern what you were looking at and
then I just I had to go back to the
question and it's the worst designed
character so just designing the look of
the character
I feel just in the spirit of the
question by the hair on his chinny chin
chin I gotta go Eric damn it similarly
came down between Eric and Danielle for
me how like me I get it
we adore you thanks man
I feel that Danielle pulled it off for
me because she mentioned the fact that
there is an in-universe reason perhaps
why Devastator looks that way he is made
up of a lot of different robots you may
not like the design but there's at least
a functionality or a reason behind it
whereas the point that she way
particularly with male Bhoja or whatever
is that's part of design is knowing your
your ability and that the character was
not designed to be even within the
ability of the film to pull it off I
thought that was a very good point I
thought she fought well against the
other two choices and so my vote goes to
Danielle all right we have won one Billy
bids can you make some sense of this all
right the most up-to-date poll at 66%
it's mabeline or mail mail boy
15% for howard the duck and 13% for the
Devastator
Wow Danielle in all of movie fights you
have won five questions in a row is a
five question streak look at that
Billy biz I know there are any other
good answers in there not a lot of love
for the Super Mario Brothers movies in
this channel design was crapped on at
some point also x-men origins Deadpool
the Michael Bay Turtles letter Joker the
horrifying CGI scorpion rock at the end
of mummy - there's some there's some
real nightmare fuel and one that I
really hated was dr. doom from fen four
stick Josh Trank's fan four stick I
thought that version of dr. doom was
just oh my god he was such a beautifully
designed character they go with this
cyber doom okay we're gonna kill Chiklis
in the Commish anti Avengers of all the
characters are just named yes our own
Avengers
alright so Danielle is up one to nil to
nil these gents looking to get on the
board question number two
alright detective Pikachu opens this
weekend shout out to we just put up
something on the detective Pikachu
junket against energy Thank You Danny
check out that video interview I have
some fun with Ryan Reynolds and the gang
from detective Pikachu but we asked what
genre other than war and mystery should
be remade starring Pokemon characters
what genre should be remade with Pokemon
characters question number two we're
going to start with player number two
Josh ready player two okay so I don't
know if this is per se a genre but I
went with the lego verse so cuz I think
we're in like a Lego genre right like
you're kind of you they've created their
own genre right and what
what do we like more than anything in
the world is a good crossover a good
amalgamation of two like we've been
talking about synergy am i right and
what's more adorable than Pikachu and a
Charizard how about these adorable
little Lego people they're always
building each other like move their
faces around they've all have fun voices
of stars that are like having a good
time I mean they even throw Batman out
there and we've already got this newer
thing with Pikachu as Ryan Reynolds just
throw all those people together be like
one giant UCB improv show but in a Lego
Pikachu pokémon verse I mean listen what
do kids love enough toys and water
pokemon toys and what are Legos they're
toys altogether you have this giant toy
movie it's literally you took your
basement collection of toys and you made
a genre movie of the Lego verse what
would the script look like does it
matter with all that cuteness is just
adorable
all right Josh this movie's gonna get
buying cuteness thank you sir Daniel
Radford
I think that story does matter sir um so
for me I chose I chose a genre that I
think would work very well in the
Pokemon universe or any münich universe
I think it's really hard to mess up I
picked a romantic comedy and I even have
a pitch for you I don't know if you want
it now or I should go ahead and save it
for later you want to give us a taste I
can give you a little taste of it um
you've got a boy coming from Pallet Town
he's selling you on it you've got a
bully coming from his town he wants to
be the best the best like no one ever
was right you've got a girl who's also
coming from her town and the both of
them are the best and they don't know
anything about each other other than by
name and they've never met before and
then all of a sudden they are on the
train to go to the championship and they
start striking up a conversation without
knowing who the other was and that's
where we start oMG we've found love in a
hopeless place around the bend Oh Eric
well I had to go to a classic genre
which is the Western because who
wouldn't want to see sheriff Pikachu
Pokemon it's Deadwood you mash them all
together or it's gonna
the most amazing thing ever you know yes
you can come back thank you can everyone
read let's come back to voicing what did
you switch it up well if the a Jeff
Bridges or Kurt Russell Birk Timothy
Olyphant if I mentioning Deadwood
there's a lot to do here you know this
is a hard-drinking Pikachu a strong
sense of justice and he's gonna clean up
this town which is filled with Pokemon
of course I just think it lends itself
immediately to so many story
possibilities you can take all the
classic characters reimagine them as
Western archetypes and you know Missy
can be the ranchers daughter you know
ash can be a kid who needs some help
from sheriff Pikachu it writes itself
really alright three very different
genres fight it out y'all I don't want
to see Pope I don't want to see my
Pokemon with alcohol problems I think
when you do that a very important part
of keeping a Pokemon movie is that it's
got to be marketable for kids you can't
market it's the same problem that Howard
the Duck had word didn't know what movie
it wanted to be straight your movie
sounds like it would be great for people
who grew up with Pokemon and can do kind
of a nod nod wink wink but at the end
it's going to be a lot of mishmash where
you know adults are not gonna buy their
kids the martini last Pokemon like you
know and how does even order a martini
I fixed the water you can see it's hard
man it's a pika teeny it's a mix between
like a peach and a Tiki thing I don't
know what I'm saying is listen alcohol
problems aside I mean they're the some
of the most funniest of all the ailments
I mean anybody see leaving Las Vegas
it's a sterile
so learn you log burnin watch a little
leaving Las Vegas it really warms the
soul listen I think we all know that the
world needs more cute and they need more
love and what shows more love and my
movie then then the Pikachu are being
hunted by somebody right the Pikachu the
Pokemon they're getting those balls
throw an atom some drunk girl at Comic
Con looking for him in the middle of the
road and gets hit by a car right people
are looking for all these Pokemon I'm
think about Pokemon go you know I'm like
trying to calm I'm writing you a little
plot here you get it
so the Pokemon are there getting chased
down by the evil humans I guess and like
who hates humans more than the Pokemon
the Lego people if we saw Will Ferrell
in the first lego movie he was putting
the Kraken on all the things gluing them
all together so you get the Legos now
they are in the Lego world the the
Pokemon are in there and they're getting
protected by Batman and wild style and
Chris Pratt and all of the people that
are in the Lego movies are building
fortresses real quick and they're
creating this place where they can hide
the Pokemon and whilst they're hiding
them they realize they have more in
common than you think
and then they form a plan to then take
out the human world and make everybody
live and harmony together now I may have
just plotted a apocalypse movie with a
baton with Legos and Pokemon but I think
you know where I'm going with this but
I'm there so for mine it's both of these
sound great I do think that people are
great you are clamoring for another
live-action Pokemon movie before they
get to a lego Pokemon movie they want to
see something that feels a little more
like the Pokemon world that they grew up
in and that's where I think you can do a
romantic comedy because you can still
get are you talking about like the the
lady in the water thing or shape of
water where he she has sex with the gut
with the fish man you're telling me
you're saying like humans are having sex
with Pokemon is this what's happened in
the Roman but you're fine
you guys are both your being not only
ignorant of my opening statement no you
will not go to me into saying that I
want Pokemon and people just see Bob
just saying Pokemon is a good wingman
for Rahm come I've never heard of
anything more boring than like let's
just say it's between I don't know Matt
Bomer and Scarlett Johansson and they're
in a rom-com together okay
and Matt Bomer is best friend it's
Pikachu he's like you need to and that's
the Pikachu that's his mom we've not
seen some of the most some of the
hottest movies of last year the Broadcom
is making a comeback detective Pikachu
one of the selling points is the noir
style mixed with these adorable
characters the Lego one just leans into
the cute that is already there with the
Tokyo my characters so it doesn't give
you anything cute very distinct the
wrong common one you know rom-com
visually don't stand out the Wester
gives you something to bounce the
pokemons off of not just the balls it
takes the it takes the whole idea the
Pokemon and mixes it up with something
that visually can really stand out I
think that is the appeal of Detective
Pikachu is seeing like putting them into
this DL boys and aliens vibe like is
that what we're going likes it's a good
movie see that but that's the thing we
already have these weird little alien
guys into cowboys and Western what do we
need some hard-partying I mean it sounds
kind of awesome nevermind you tell them
is how they look in in live-action
because we've already seen but from what
I have seen and I you know unfortunately
there's no Love Actually the movie Legos
are not live-action Legos are animated
or at least we are considered to be
black action now unless you is less it's
just you crash in Legos together my
understanding is that the thing that
most audiences came away from with the
Pokemon movie is they've really really
really loved being able to see their
Pokemon in live-action that was what
sold the movie the movie yes people are
excited to see detective Pikachu but
more people were like how are we going
to make this work in this world but as
soon as they started showing those
images of Pokemon being in live-action
you see how cute Pikachu is everything
else so when you add in a love element
you're just doing
more of what people already wanted to
see people love romantic comedies they
love those you already have a grown in
romantic comedy conflict when you have
two trainers that are going up against
each other they don't know who both of
them are they wind up meeting together
it's like a Roman battle but it's like a
rom-com in hacker's right where they
recognize that they need the two of you
know each other to make each other
better and then they wind up falling in
love so you have love and you have
adorable things that someone for
everyone it's a four-quadrant movie you
have the cuteness of the Pokemon you
have the romance for the people who want
to see romance you have the action of
Pokemon battles and you have whatever
that fourth quadrant is a movie in
another adorable hat and people love
that Detective hat and won't they love
him in that cowboy hat I think they'll
love them even more are you gonna have
the Pokemon ride horses of course yeah
yeah like a hat on a hat
I mean Pikachu and Mewtwo in a classic
Western showdown except then of course
they're gonna use their powers not guns
we're gonna give you everything you what
is the Pokemon slogan catch them all is
that correct gotta count you you got to
catch them all see you missed out it
could have been you got to catch them
all including their heart and that could
have been yours josh final thought here
we go okay listen did I confuse people
with my description of what my movie
look like probably but could they see it
and that is a big yes we have never even
until this movie came out we never even
contemplated the fact that in a lego
verse the Pokemon could exist and could
exist in harmony and what does this
world need more than Avatar sequels its
harmony and we are getting that with a
Pokemon lego movie the cuteness overload
and you're not even talking about the
box office with how many times kids are
gonna beg their parents to go see poke a
Lego like a poke
Lego poke all right poke you're the one
Josh quit poking my leg Danielle again I
think that when you're combining these
genres and you're getting a chance to
show you've got something for the whole
family this could be a Christmas movie
you could do this around Valentine's Day
you could package this for any time
around a three-day weekend this is going
to be something that the you know the
teenage girls and the teenage boys who
love both Pokemon and who
or you know or dipping their toes in the
romance they're gonna want to see this
is gonna be like a you got mail except
it's gonna be you got squirtle or
whatever whoa
what those elements together and you
have what could potentially be a huge
sleeper hit plus there's already gonna
be enough of a financial drain when
you're doing the live-action real stuff
so now you can just put it all on sound
stages and when you put it on sound
stages you can do it at Universal you
can do it other places and you can wind
up saving some money there as well pull
go pull all right Thank You Danielle
Eric I think the detective Pikachu is
setting a great template for showing the
pokemons characters the familiar
characters in a distinct visual style
genre and that is what the Western
offers you know when you look at a
Western you know you're looking at
Western right away and then you put the
Pokemon characters into it and that's
what gets the great counterpoint that I
don't think your concepts do it takes
the Western which is this you know
rough-and-tumble concept puts the
Pokemon in it and then of course it
gives you all these possibilities to
have them act out the classic gunfight
the classic saloon brawl but with
Pokemon powers I think it's just there
there's so many possibilities there that
people would really really embrace
whereas the other ones they just feel
like they're leaning a little too much
into the cuteness which is great but I
think you need to take the cuteness and
put it against something harsh and
thereupon gives you sheriff Pikachu
which is why you should choose him all
right who will we choose Dan Merle take
us to the fact zone I always like that
and I make this mistake a lot even as a
Lego enthusiasts leg achoo the plural of
Lego and this is from Lego so it's not
Legos they they ask that the plural be
referred to as Lego bricks or Lego toys
this is a quote from Lego Lego is
singular and always followed by a noun
such as Lego bricks so Gigi's
technically by Legos right ranking you
should never say Legos in a plural form
when referring to their problem go of
saying Legos
yes exactly also the kragle was the
stuff from the leg
the Kraken would also be cool
but it was all hey RA GL the crying it
nice nicely done dan dan thoughts on
this argument I changed my mind several
times but I ended up winding up siding
with Eric I thought that josh is scented
a lot more just like a cross over to me
more than like embracing a new genre and
Danielle was actually not bored with but
as the longer the argument went it was a
rom-com but then threw in pokémon
battles and then there's a lot of focus
on the budget and being in the studio
and I felt like Eric particularly
disclosing was I liked the fact it's
like you take the things about Pokemon
but you were merging it with a genre
you're not just crossing it over but the
idea of putting it against something
that has a little bit of a harder edge
integrating Pokemon into that that
sounded like the best and most coherent
vision to me so I went with Eric thank
you Dan
yeah Josh you took me on a real
delightful journey there and I've got
quite an adventure but yeah it's not the
Pokemon it's an adventure
yes but I got a little overwhelmed and a
little bit scared and then I retreated
into my shell squirtle a turtle shell
guy yeah yeah right squirtle Rhys a
turtle a lot of them like you yes
onomatopoeia but came down to for me to
for again to Danielle and Eric and yeah
at the end it for much of the same
reasoning that Dan stated like it was a
little bit more on like who the movie
would appeal to and this I was just like
oh I'd like to see Pokemon in these
iconic like a Western touchstone scenes
so yeah I also want Eric Eric gets the
point where was the pole at Billy he run
me up there's love
the internet agreed with you guys
because 51% went with Western 27% for
romantic comedy and that's weird that
math doesn't add up 10% for Lego verse
because I've never played a Pokemon game
never watching Pokemon anything so I was
just going in cold guys I'm gonna go out
on a limb and say josh mokuba might be
in the same boat also what genre meant
Lego is not a genre although I was
interested in your pitch for Danielle
that the Pokemon be having sex with
humans it is one for Danielle one for
Eric mokuba's looking to get on the
board here we go crush number three
Godzilla king of the monsters director
Mike Doherty says he wants to make a
Godzilla sequel set during prehistoric
times we asked what current movie
franchise should get a follow up set in
ancient or prehistoric times not like
cable guy that was set in a medieval day
he's a part of it what franchise should
be set an ancient or prehistoric times
and let's start with his radford you
want someone who's going to be able to
pull off the stunts you want someone
who's going to be able to run and jump
off of tough things you want someone
who's going to take on all of us by
itself which is why I chose the Mission
Impossible series to go back to ancient
or prehistoric times
I picked prehistoric times I think that
there is nothing more compelling than
the idea of Tom Cruise jumping off a
Stegosaurus jumping off of a t-rex and I
think it would be very easy to do in a
Mission Impossible movie those movies
are already impossible missions so if
we're setting them back in time it would
be very easy for all those characters to
go back in time
what are they trying to get it never
matters you know what you're there for
is the action what you're there for is
to see you know Tom Cruise swinging off
a saber-tooth tooth and it wouldn't be
historically accurate to so I can say
things like that are there cavemen maybe
none of this would matter is he gonna
use a caveman face as a mask so he can
hide through the caveman to get to where
he needs to go he definitely will you
get all of those really fun Mission
Impossible elements and you put them in
the ancient world you give them
dinosaurs you give us Mission Impossible
all right Mission Impossible going back
to prehistoric times Erik so I had to go
with the amazing franchise called The
Fast and the Furious also going to
prehistoric times yeah you know you say
Tom Cruise Ethan Hunt jumping off t-rex
is cool and I agree you know it's even
cooler
Vin Diesel and a Dodge Charger launching
off a t-rex in that car and probably
making like a 300 3,000 mile jump that
he shouldn't be able to make I just
think that you know I've for years I've
been campaigning for a fast in the
various Jurassic Park crossover
Universal you should still do it but if
they're not gonna do it and I don't
think there are this is the next best
thing you know we've seen DOM and his
family take on a lot of challenges but
taking on prehistoric times and
dinosaurs I think it gives you
everything you'd want in entertainment
yeah you know Chris Pratt riding his
motorcycle alongside some dinosaurs that
was fun but if you take Michelle
Rodriguez and Tyrese gunning their cars
alongside with some dinosaurs you've
just reached like movie nirvana I don't
see how it gets better than that
you know it's a who's more furious than
dinosaurs by the way if they're pissed
off it just adds to the title it's right
there fast nefarious meets t-rex we got
to do it all right shout out Tyrese jobs
in the Shaw Soros here uh listen I think
we all know that these are two very good
ideas but what we really want is a
prehistoric set Pirates of the Caribbean
now mostly all the people that they're
playing are kind of cavemen I mean it
kind of already fits in the situation
they're wearing just ramshackle clothes
on a boat made of apparently wood that
just like shadows and the boats never
the boats never sink they just gotta
hang around and roll
[Music]
pretty free woody and but what they you
know they fought a crack and I guess in
that one and then the Keith Jones and
the other and so or Keith Richards I'm
not really sure but what I do know cuz
giant Depp was this fire anyway right
right okay anyway anywho what I will say
is nothing quite says Pirates of the
Caribbean let's take it to the next
level like them out in the middle the
ocean and dinosaurs just come out of
nowhere and start attacking the ships
can you imagine Johnny Depp's reaction
when a dinosaur puffs others I don't
know it's a terrible Johnny Depp what
I'm saying is that we what we've got
here are pirates verse dana soars we in
Pirates are always entertaining and the
dinosaurs to it there's nothing that
will equal the amount that of money that
Disney will spend to put these lifelike
dinosaurs in in the beautiful Caribbean
fighting-men of boats I mean it is a
beautiful part of the world there is no
one can deny that let's fight it out
guys here's the thing fairies already
offers so much and yes obviously for
this project we're getting everyone VIN
and Dwane they're gonna work their
issues out and you will see the rock
punch out multiple velociraptors well
you will see Helen Mirren riding a
triceratops it's gonna have everything
my major question for you is so you're
setting us back in the time of the
dinosaurs you are driving cars
how you gonna power them cars ain't no
oil yet family family Tom why don't we
power these he's like we got something
that no one else got and he's like the
power of family power someone comes up
with that technology soon cuz we could
definitely use it here and judge if
they're pirates and they're back in the
Jurassic times yeah what are they
stealing what are they packing here's
what happened
basically like they're going down Meg
style so they the the boat made of wood
wrecks into a a large large gold mine
that is protected by dinosaurs okay and
these dinosaurs like Smaug are very
obsessed with the gold coming in and
then they attack the boat blows up
everything and it can blow up dinosaurs
this I guarantee you they don't need oil
as your as your argument for fast and
furious they definitely don't need wood
Cheers one again telling you if you give
me prehistoric Mission Impossible it is
the stick I don't want Tom Cruise and is
not quite like giving like he's making
these dirty and he's like fighting in
the mud supplies or all of these Mission
Impossible movies are about finding
something that is out of this world this
Mission Impossible movie is about to be
about time travel you are out making
your set in the Jurassic period if we
want to be protective about what the
question is it's about putting it in an
ancient period that drives off the end
of the world
that takes about complete okay - a
brontosaurus with gnaw stripe strapped
to his side's okay is there gonna share
technology become you know kindred
spirits with these dinosaurs obviously
the good ones there's gonna be some
battle so what is that confidence
there's give me some bad ones there's
gonna be like some evil like Owen Shaw
dinosaur cuz I want to saw a bad guy
he's gonna ride the bad dinosaur he was
saying I said we're gonna see you know
the two Shaw brothers have to find it
out it's gonna be very symbolic because
the dinosaurs are also brothers and so
it's like brother brother brother
brother and then everyone's gonna have
giant leaps it's gonna be like cliff to
cliff and you know DOM and the dinosaurs
are gonna not eat another inch either
with respect you know when they run out
of things to piggyback off of Danielle's
thing you're gonna have dinosaurs
pulling the cars at like amazing you're
gonna have it all because you're gonna
have some parts with the diner's are
pulling the cars when you're gonna also
have the part where the cars are the
dinosaurs are on top of two cars one
foot onto each car right and they're
just gunning it and DOM and Letty look
at each other like we're doing this and
that's what they do like the biggest
leap of all over a fire pit at the end
and helen mirren is cheering them I
think what you're missing out here is
the point when a bunch of pirates
swashbuckle sword fight against actual
dinosaurs listen you can swashbuckle
some whippin Stegosaurus you can
swashbuckle against the pterodactyl all
whilst protecting her drunken it may
have scurry and there are no lemons to
help them out in the prehistoric times
if you have all of the technology that
will come along with Mission Impossible
because this is not just a movie where
obviously you dinosaur no I told you
this is gonna be one of those ones
because people do not understand how
time works nobody understands Mission
Impossible they're too confusing yeah
that's why it was for me they are very
confusing no one understands what
happening and you know why because you
don't care it's looks like fast in there
is no one cares what it's actually about
well you guys family cruise climbing on
top roll this in your final philosophy
I'm Tom Cruise
climbing on top of a Stegosaurus you
want to see people trying to find the
elements that they need of this time
machine so that they could take it back
to our time you want to see the spy
versus spy stuff and appearing where
they're also it's not just man against
man it's man against nature they're also
having to worry about
fighting against these dinosaurs and yes
occasionally using the dinosaurs and
while you know the craziness of the plot
of fast and furious is part of the
reason why people do love those movies
and I agree with this one you get the
craziness but it's also something that
makes a little more sense than just the
dinosaurs or brothers because how would
you know that
all right mrs. character is very smart
and you can figure that out it's true
and then you've got you know Charlie's
throne cipher she'd be riding in on a
pterodactyl there's just so many things
that offers you and the thing about fast
and furious of course is it doesn't obey
any rules of reality not that there's
other franchises don't go out of their
way to out of reality too but you know
the fact that they don't even obey the
laws of physics and fast enough furious
so you're just taking this concept to
its full potential you know you were
taking dinosaurs everyone loves
dinosaurs right but what is the most
insane thing to bounce off of them and
it is the pure bleeding burning heart of
dom lenny and the whole gang and going
as fast and furious as they possibly can
in their ultimate adventure what have we
found that we love most in this country
that is the Pirates of the Caribbean
ride at Disneyland now what is the other
thing that we love 1993 is Jurassic Park
put those together in a ride and you
have my movie what did I just I
described the beautiful waters of the
Caribbean you add dinosaurs to that your
two movies depend all your franchises
depend on technology maybe not the first
couple fast and furious is when they
started drifting in Tokyo then they
start getting into like world espionage
and everybody's got different things
yours it's one giant computer problem
that I don't understand every their
faces and GPS devices what does the port
of the pirates need they just need wood
right to him they need wood to make a
ship and they need their swashbuckling
ways to take on the dinosaurs and when
you boil it all down to it what happens
in prehistoric times it's man versus
beast boat verse brontosaurus
bing-bang-boom
pirates the Carribean dinosaurs what
around what around man
I mean that was that was just fun like
you guys are just like trying to top
each other and it was I mean just being
this close to that heat man damn hotels
gone on the facts own Josh was roundly
scolded for purportedly advancing a Flat
Earth theory I would remind the court
that the Pirates of the Caribbean have
been at World's End before and could
return thusly and it's it's canonically
true so I'm sticking up Franco thanks
Dan I appreciate it for everything there
is and the last limit I was trying to
look up the veracity of the fact that
the could would lemons have been around
to help cure scurvy in three historic
times I the the earliest fossil records
date lemons back about eight million
years dinosaurs existed 65 million years
ago so it is very likely that lemons
perhaps would not have been there
accidental biology scurvy prevention
purposes so that's what I spend my time
doing on this I mean there's a lot of
ridiculousness and that are in that
round but actually that that's what I
have thank you Dan
dan only checks the facts on my
arguments like my things I don't I know
thanks lemon does you really powering a
car is it known
it's back so that I don't make mistakes
they just correct so the just the very
notion of these potential of any
potential movie that's going to go back
to prehistoric times and you know F with
Dinosaurs it's already cuckoo coconuts
and so I figured they'd have workaround
so like I mean Danielle had some great
takedowns of like how are they gonna
power the car and you know josh is like
totally would but I'm like you know what
the screenwriters will get there when
they get there they'll open up a
wormhole and knock something that would
happen you know so I so it came down to
the most bombast to me and at the very
end it's just like you know Helen Mirren
riding a dinosaur the NAS straps to the
side of like I've let it slip and dynast
like just the most bombast came from
right here so I got a go Erik Erik
you're so I don't know you're speaking
to me today that one for Erik Dan I have
Tom Cruise on the brain but not for the
reason that Danielle would want because
to paraphrase a line from a Tom Cruise
movie Eric you had me at Helen Mirren
writing and also just part of the part
of the game is is reacting to the
curveballs that everyone throws at you
and I thought that Eric by far just is
just like oh how are they gonna power
the cars
family yeah the mood I think I think
Eric put more into the thought process
in the movie itself would have done if
such a movie were to exist and I yeah it
was it was embracing the ridiculousness
of it plus and the actual answers to the
volleys put against them I go with Eric
again all right Eric you get that point
to any to one leave Billy what the
Internet think about the proceedings
well how much like fans that boo John
Cena but still buy his merchandise you
wouldn't know it from the check but
overwhelmingly with 50 percent pirates
of the Carribean
26% fast and furious 22% mission
impossible because why do you spy on
dinosaurs it's the only one that makes
sense you know what Josh you are
America's Sweetheart and the next host
of Jeopardy thank you sir
but you will not be moving on to the
speed you know what hell it's always a
pleasure here being with you guys at
screen junkies this continues my trend
of not winning any points it's always a
pleasure just to be here with you fine
folks your mayhem really tickled me so
thank you for being here man welcome all
right so it is Eric with 2 it is
Danielle with 1 and they are about to
throw down in the speed round y'all
ready for this maybe thank you all right
question 1 of the speed round oh and it
works the Slee I'll ask the question
shout out your answer first person
answer gets 20 seconds to elaborate the
other player will get 20 seconds and
then 10 second rebuttals in the same
order okay here we go
Will Smith rapped a little bit of friend
like me on The Tonight Show this week
what rapper should play an iconic Disney
character and a remake
we need the rapper and the Disney
character what rapper should play a
Disney character give us the rapper and
the jay-z Prince Charming we have jay-z
and Prince Charming I'm gonna go with
that LL Cool J and Lightning McQueen LL
and lightning were cleaning from cars
all right Danielle we heard you first 20
seconds began when you speak jay-z has
already won the biggest princess of our
time that is Beyonce so we know that he
has the power to be able to charm any
woman that might be out there I love the
idea of him trying to find his bride the
right person for him he's at a dance as
a hood what's up from Jersey by jay-z
impersonation they meet they fall in
love they look at each other jay-z you
know he's he's already he's a
billionaire I will also go with charm as
a key word here LL Cool J has plenty of
it so does Lightning McQueen but he can
also mix bravado with sort of that aw
shucks nature and I think
that's Lightning McQueen to a tee so he
can be the big city guy in the small
town who starts to fit in and find his
groove there I think LL Cool J would
have the perfect attitude to put that
through and to drive very very fast at
the same time LL Cool J's entire career
has been based on BOM Bassett has been
based on him being better than everyone
else has been based on kissing his mouth
whereas with Jay Z we've seen in later
years he has been humbled by lemonade
he has been humbled LL Cool J will knock
you out so he's a fighter he's ready to
race but then at the same time you know
he's going back to Cali he's on the road
he's showing how he's traveling and
there you have it right there Lightning
McQueen meets LL Cool J they both start
with L by the way so it's meant to be
all right good stuff you guys
William business Patterson as much as I
don't want to go against Queen B I felt
like I got more about the personal
history of Jay Z than I did how he would
tie in necessarily as a Disney character
whereas Erik both his rebuttals were
purely about how he would make a good
Lightning McQueen specifically so I'm
gonna go with Erik I I actually saw it
the other way I feel like the qualities
of Jay Z that we heard spoke to me as
why he'd be the better Prince Charming
as opposed to we just heard the song
like that I mean the songs don't
necessarily make the guy if that makes
sense and I ever do that or do they but
in this instance for me know so I'm
going Danielle with Jay Z Dan yes I
think that a little bit too much of
Erik's argument was tied up and just
saying things about LL Cool J whereas
they like yes I like the approach of
he's already charmed the the princess of
our time the Queen anyway so I am also
going with that
Danielle you just tied this thing up to
two great arguments on that speed around
the question you guys thank you
question two of the speed around Anna
Lily Amir poor is making a female-driven
remake of cliffhanger
what actress should take on the Stallone
role Charley's throne it's like I've
never heard of an actress in my entire
life
what is actress Zooey Saldana oh okay
good choices here Eric we heard you
first so shoulders thrown obviously has
shown her action credentials she shows
that she can be very tough credibly
tough in a film like cliffhanger I think
we would you know a completely buyer in
that role also of course she's an
Academy award-winning actress so when it
comes to the drama that pay post the oh
my god I left like let someone go and
they fell to their death and I have to
get over this I think she'd bring it and
she'd bring it in a real way so you can
believe her fighting the bad guy no one
knows what it's like to have been on the
other side of that cliff being led to
their death then Zoe Saldana
she has been an amazing action action
star and three of the biggest franchises
in the world she knows how to handle
action she knows how to handle the pace
that paid those she has been basically
an action star for her entire career as
well as being able to show the owner
ability in those roles it a rule like
this you have to just bring the attitude
that I'm making a leap of faith and I'm
going to do it no one is gonna doubt you
and I think Charlie's has that to a tee
you just believe in her completely in a
role like this
that's why she's sort of the epitome of
a great action hero there is no doubt
with the zoe saldana because we have
gotten to see her in so many of these
roles additionally there is so much
dealing with the pain of that and yet
Charlize has an Oscar but this could be
a moment freshman for a Zoe Saldana to
really show her acting chops dan what do
you got mmm two good arguments I think
it was ability versus experience really
and I think that so much of Danielle's
argument was was about her past roles
but I was a little more John to Erik's
roles about why Charlize herself would
what she would contribute as an actor to
the role so I'm going with Eric yeah for
similar reason
I felt danced sorry I thought Eric
spelled out the gravitas in and that
Charlize would bring whereas she Zoe
certainly has the resume but for similar
reasons I'm going with Eric as well Eric
you get the point they're moving to a
3-2 lead question three of the speed
round so we got it chapter 2 trailer
yeah oh yeah
so which clown would you prefer to have
as a roommate who'd make the better
roommate
Pennywise or Jared Leto's Joker Joker
okay so we have Leto's Joker from
Danielle penny wise for Eric Danielle
Jared Leto's Joker knows how to bring
out the fun and everyone that he's
around he loves to play practical jokes
and if ever there was a time when you
wanted to get your neighbors off your
back you wanted to get your landlord off
of your back he could just send them
something really creepy or he could just
if you're behind in rent he'll just blow
up the whole apartment building and you
can move on and start a new life
somewhere else he is we knows as opposed
to feeling like you're living with the
total douchebag with stupid tattoos
Pennywise brings creativity and fun and
he you never know what's gonna happen
and he can make things visually
interesting all the time he can change
his sperm he can keep you excited and
entertained he can change it to your
friends your family whoever you want to
see he can be it he can be the best
friend you've ever wanted or the worst
enemy if that's what you want to yell at
that day Pennywise you know just use it
come and keep it different living with
douchebags with too many tattoos is how
most of us spent our 20s unfortunately
so that wouldn't be very different for
anyone else however would Pennywise you
constantly be coming home and being like
why does my house smell like children
and then all of a sudden there would be
a child in your eyes box so there would
be Pennywise you know just keeps things
changing up and you know he also he's
he's lived for centuries and centuries
he can tell you great stories all the
time he can tell you about the past and
a really learning way and you can learn
a lot and you can have fun while you're
doing it
[Laughter]
there's no right answer I look just
because there is no right answer and
Eric was dealt a terrible card and was
he did his damnedest like he could tell
you lots of things better than the
tattooed douchebag I did live with again
so I'll go Pennywise that's wonderful
Pennywise dan yeah I feel like the
blowing of the apartment thing would
only work once or twice that what you
really want the roommate who is what you
need them to me that day so I think that
was a good line I'm also gonna go with
Eric Eric oh man you just won
[Applause]
Eric yeah you're first for all movie
fights yeah you took the day nicely done
please go ahead give some shoutouts sing
a song do whatever you can follow me on
Twitter Instagram at the Eric Goldman
you can find my writing at random calm
and you should go to the we enjoy
wrestling podcast if you want to hear
people talk about wrestling and enjoying
it alright dueling wrestling podcast
subscribe download all of these podcasts
Josh McKoon penn state just won their
seventh of eighth national championships
in wrestling
yeah Josh mccoon Twitter and Instagram
you guys can check me out on Collider
every single day and Clara live you can
check out the Josh mccoon show in the
afternoons with Josh again Josh thank
you for just going off on amazing ten
bird always well played super delightful
yeah you know what
you didn't pitch the shutout today but
you took it to the limit oh it's you
only look you put your shutout once yeah
and that's it like and that's it's great
for your career but if you again if you
want to find me you can find me here I
am on screen junkies I'm on sju on
fandom I write things I write a bunch of
stuff and I'm gonna go back and go do
some more writing now you can find me
I'm Danielle Radford on Twitter Danielle
all underscore advert on Instagram Thank
You Danielle
damn rural so what's how's the weekend
shaping up box office wise looking like
an Avengers three-peat but detective
Pikachu also looking like it might score
a nice debut but you never know what
these things oh right on
yeah lots of Avengers lots of you know
franchises it's summer yeah I mean it's
lots of repeat viewings fueling that any
ready feelings I mine was one of them
last week yes yeah a lot of people going
to see the event there's a lot of times
right on Billy biz yeah a lot of cool
stuff coming up here on screen talking
some fandom next week next week it's the
finale of Game of Thrones we are gonna
be going with our watching Thrones shows
live Sunday night so we're gonna be
doing some just reactions to that and
then also next week super excited we're
finally going to be able to reveal why
myself Roth it's Spencer max what we've
been working on and why we've been m.i.a
from sju for a while
we can finally unveil it so cool things
coming to sju next week stay tuned can I
might spoil that announcement cuz I
believe it's the casting of John Lithgow
in the cliffhanger remake because you
know they wanted to Charley's Theron but
Charley Steiner Zach's gonna play the
John let's go part
Wow thank you so but listen to Billy
tune in next week for that and I'm Hal
Rudnick follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at how Rudnick whoo-hoo owl
nation thanks for watching thanks GT
thanks Billy mr. doing double-duty
bye-bye
you